honest honestly now i feel like
christmas for me is more of like
it's it's christmas when i spend it with
the the people right so it doesn't have
to be on christmas day
yeah just around the time you know give
or take as long as i hang out with some
friends it could be like a week a few
drinks
you know just be like let's just do an
early christmas you know exchange a few
gifts you know
i i i do want to do something on
christmas because there's i do
i've i've had like christmases where
i've done nothing before and it
is a bit depressing when you're just
like by yourself or
do nothing you go in your timeline
everyone's opening presents with each
other
just like what if you're having like
christmas day the next day with your
friends it's like all right whatever i'm
getting it
i think it was worse is new years alone
for some reason i've had new years alone
before yeah same i have two
and for some reason it's more depressing
than christmas alone i don't know why
i i spent new year's one year in the
worst [ __ ] way possible
i think i was like 16 um and i was
working up at a
ski falls the first time i was working
up at a ski field and uh
we're in the middle of hokkaido in the
mountains it's like [ __ ] minus
30 degrees in a [ __ ] blizzard and of
course i'm working that day
i'm outside in the [ __ ] blizzard
shoveling snow but
on top of that one of the hotels had a
blocked sewage system
and i had to get in there with a [ __ ]
shovel so imagine a 16 year old
right right in the middle of a [ __ ]
blizzard in the mountains
literally shoveling [ __ ] out of the
ground
yeah right and literally the moment
we've unclogged the thing
my boss was like oh the oh it's the next
year yeah happy new year
yeah we did nice but also it was like
cool my my first uh experience of the
new year is the
smell of frozen [ __ ] it's only up from
there right yeah
i mean what yeah true sure it was a good
year but it wasn't it wasn't the
greatest start to the year that's for
sure
i feel like new year is like the biggest
hoax that everyone's put over the world
oh it's
it's never as good as you want it to be
it's it's it's hyped up as
the biggest party of the year and nobody
knows what they're doing until the day
before i
swear to [ __ ] everything's full like you
can't get in anywhere
everywhere's overpriced everywhere is
full
everyone's doing something aside from
you for some
reason even though you ask a week before
hey what are you doing for new year's
they don't [ __ ] know yes somehow on
new year's you're that one [ __ ] who
just has nothing nothing planned
it's always the worst way like the last
day of the year you have the biggest
fomo of the year
it is always somehow i always more often
not end up just
doing nothing like new year's eve always
being like [ __ ] i missed out yeah yeah
like yeah you might as well rename new
year's eve fomo party
because that's what it is that's what
new year's eve is everyone goes out
because they're afraid of missing out
because i've spent new years alone
before and it is depressing yeah
it's it's really [ __ ] depressing
shout out to the people out there who
are just gonna be alone but like
at this at the same time some of my
worst [ __ ] nights have been on new
year's eve as well that's true
it's never a good night it's always just
so stressful because you can never get
like a taxi either
yeah if you need to get back because
everyone's getting tired it only took me
one year's eve of going out to know that
all right
next new year's eve from now on is just
house parties the only people who win
are uber drivers man they're the only
ones winning
church [ __ ] man i god news is the worst
the [ __ ] i just realized how much i hate
new year's yeah it's like gotta do
something i don't want to be
sad like you're you're either sad or
you're having a [ __ ] night yeah
or you're broke there's there's there's
no there's no there's no
there's no perfect new year's there's no
perfect new year's eve yeah that's true
like
i [ __ ] hate news
do you guys have any plans for this new
year's no no i'll figure that out when
it comes to it yeah
you'll figure that out on the screen we
just said
they always do this thing for new year's
right where everyone's like we could go
here
like everyone is always like yeah well
which one of them throwing suggestions
yeah everyone
throws suggestions around new year's but
yeah no one wants to commit to it
because you don't want to be the [ __ ]
who took them to a place that's full
right yeah right and then it's like well
then what like we're in we're in
because no one wants to commit because
everyone knows okay this place is going
to be overpriced and full
yeah um let's let's let's leave this
until like the last moment because the
thing is
there is no good place on new year's eve
but you have to go to a place
right like your maybe your friend can
get you into somewhere and then you can
only get like half of your friends
right and then it's like well what the
[ __ ] happening do we just leave half
our friends and tell them to go [ __ ]
themselves
yeah but and like the best the best new
year's eve
like party would probably be a house
party but like no one wants to host a
new year's eve house party
right sure it's always like it's it's
always like a voting ballot that you
just don't want and even then it's like
do i really like everyone at this party
yeah like some other people because like
as
as like a teenager if you were hosting a
new year's eve house party that house
was getting trashed oh yeah
you knew it was getting trash and no
matter how small you wanted it to be
it was never going to be small because
it's a new year's eve
yeah but yeah because you don't want it
to be like because it's somehow like
reverse like depressing when it's like
too small three people
too small and it's depressing yeah but
like i like i swear like as a teenager
you'd have like [ __ ] sniffer dogs
trying trying to sniff out house parties
man you're just like where can we where
can we go boys where can we go because
i've heard in the grapevine that there
is a house party somewhere around here
you know you'd always know that one mate
who would know someone who'd known
someone who's like
who'd heard about a house party
happening yeah yeah i've
not proud admit definitely spent the new
years just going to house parties that
like were just full and then not being
able to get into any of that right
and then i was like i guess we're just
going to tesco's and getting a few beers
and just
sitting outside all right i've had some
of the most like the pressing you've
seen
like trying to like house hunt a house
party right
and we'd just be literally we'd
literally be at like six
and like the time we would start and be
like okay who who
who's who's heard some rumors we're
going to follow up on everyone
phone phone up all your contacts like
everything like a [ __ ] l.a noir
gather clues yeah right now call up all
the favors you know
like because no no one wants to no one
wants to be that guy who invites
who invites everyone to the house right
but sometimes
you know i may he owes you a favor who's
at the house party you're like
yo just just give me the general
directions yeah come on the last day of
the year
yeah do a solo yeah or when if you had a
you've had a friend who just got
blackout drunk before midnight and it's
like [ __ ] man
i've been there before you like gotta
[ __ ] take care of them now and gotta
[ __ ] i've had some new years where i've
like passed out at like 10 p.m
just like i see you next year
those are the days